[Musique]
c'était il ya quelques mois au printemps
dernier la révolte dans les usines du
sud est de la chine
les grèves dans les usines ne sont pas
chose courante en chine leurs aînés une
fronde ouvrière se propage à travers le
pays dans la région de shenzhen que
certains appellent l'atelier du monde
c'est l'ébullition pour la première fois
plusieurs mouvements de grève ont touché
des géants de l'électronique qui sont
installés en date ou iota brothers sans
oublier foxconn premier sous traitant
d'apple frappé lui par une forte vague
de suicides dans ses usines
six mois après la révolte des petites
mains chinoises est loin d'être terminée
le 15 octobre dernier les mille trois
cents ouvriers de lysine rico où l'on
fabrique des imprimantes et des
photocopieurs pour le monde entier
décide de cesser le travail
[Musique]
immédiatement la police et envoyés pour
mater la grève
une semaine plus tard les extérieurs de
l'usiné sont toujours surveillés par la
police
malgré tout nous parvenons en rencontré
des ouvriers
[Musique]
paroles interdite sur les prémices d'une
véritable fronde ouvrière le blocage a
duré neuf jours
nous voulions poursuivre le mouvement
mais le gouvernement a envoyé la milice
la police nous a forcés à reprendre le
travail et on a dû travailler ensuite
sous leur contrôle
au cours de l'entretien ces ouvriers
nous montre des photos et des vidéos de
ce mouvement capturés avec leurs
téléphones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on y voit la milice populaire qui casse
le piquet de grève avant de forcer les
ouvriers à reprendre le travail
[Musique]
six films films ça
on a dû travailler 10 à 11 heures par
jour sous le contrôle de la police ou
d'hommes envoyés par le gouvernement
puis le mouvement s'est atténuée
doucement petit à petit voilà comment ça
s'est passé
le jour où nous avons repris le travail
la milice est venu nous faire peur dans
le dortoir le soir à minuit nous n'avons
pas eu d'autre choix que de reprendre le
travail
on n'a pas eu le choix je dois respecter
un temps déterminé de quelques secondes
pour chaque tâche c'est impossible de
dépasser le temps imparti
parce que je suis surveillé et si vous
dépassez le temps il se passe quoi on
doit payer les amendes
ils sont toujours en train de vérifier
si on ne fait pas exprès de prendre du
temps on doit payer les amendes une à
deux fois par mois au début je n'étais
pas habitué aux cadences jeu perdait de
l'argent
regardez nous on travaille si dur man
ray tellement fatigués on est déjà foutu
on n'a pas de vie au final les ouvriers
n'aurait rien obtenu de la part de la
direction
chez ricoh comme dans les autres usines
installées en chine les syndicats
seraient systématiquement du côté de la
direction
pour ces trois autres ouvriers de rico
cette situation est intolérable
tout d'abord il faut savoir que lors de
la création du syndicat de notre
entreprise
c'est un des vice-présidents de
l'entreprise qui a été désigné en tant
que président du syndicat 112 euros par
mois pour 10 à 11 heures minimum par
jour six jours sur sept sans aucune
possibilité d'évolution
à ce tarif là ces ouvriers ne croit plus
le salaire des ouvriers en chine est
trop bas dans ses usines tu peux y
passer toute sa vie en gagnant toujours
le même salaire qu'au début le
développement de la société et de
l'économie ne doit pas se réaliser sur
le dos des ouvriers comme nous
rien n'a été résolu il y aura de plus en
plus de grève la direction du groupe
quant à elle nous a fait savoir que des
discussions avec les ouvriers étaient en
cours
depuis six mois la deuxième puissance
économique mondiale est en proie à une
révolte de ses ouvriers en chine
le fossé entre les classes sociales
aisées les couches les plus pauvres se
creuse de plus en plus pour éviter un
soulèvement social 27 régions chinoises
ont d'ores et déjà augmenté les salaires
d'environ 20%
la voix des ouvriers en colère se fait
de plus en plus entendre à travers le
pays notamment sur des sites internet et
des radios relié depuis hong kong saône
spécial rétrocédée à la chine en 97 où
la liberté d'expression est là bas
garantis
[Musique]
on m'a appelé pour tenir un piquet de
grève
avec dix ouvriers et peu de temps après
on m'a dit que j'allais être arrêté vous
avez été interpellé
vous avez passé combien de temps en
prison six jours les jours en dong fang
anime une émission la voix des ouvriers
sur radio free asia en donnant la parole
aux salariés chinois
il espère que c'est toute la chine qui
entendra la détresse de ses salariés des
violations des droits des travailleurs
deviennent de plus en plus graves
la seule option qui leur reste c'est la
confrontation est de plus en plus de
gens n'ont plus rien à perdre
c'est ça la vraie nouveauté
cette émission de radio c'est un combat
pour hong kong en 1989
eng a été torturé pendant deux années
passées dans les geôles chinoises pour
avoir créé le premier syndicat
indépendant après avoir été expulsée
vers hong kong en 1993 il crée une
organisation qui milite pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
en chine
le gouvernement ne peut plus ignorer les
droits des ouvriers comme il l'a fait
auparavant
et du coup il travaille maintenant sur
de nouvelles lois pour protéger les
ouvriers pas salaire durée de travail
excessive management militaire finition
et harcèlement inhumain malgré de
nombreux rapports accablants sur les
conditions de travail dans les usines
les autorités chinoises tiennent avant
tout à offrir une main-d'oeuvre
extrêmement bon marché aux investisseurs
étrangers
des conditions que dénonce geoffrey
crotales porte parole de lo ng china
labour bulletin basé à hong kong
goffman la plupart des gouvernements
locaux n'ont qu'un seul objectif attirer
des investissements développer leur
petit royaume
il veut le faire plaisir au patron
ils veulent que les coûts de main
d'oeuvre reste bas pour que les
investisseurs viennent chez eux et non
pas chez le voisin
retour dans la zone économique spéciale
de shenzhen devant l'une des usines
foxconn le plus grand sous traitant
d'apple
neuf cent mille employés dans tout pays
qui fabrique entre autres 137000 iphone
par jour dans un restaurant à proximité
de l'une de ses usines
nous rencontrons trois jeunes chinois de
16 et 17 ans ces ados confection à
longueur de journée les puces
électroniques du téléphone de la firme
apple mais surprise aucun des trois n'a
encore vu un iphone en vrai entier le
premier qu'ils verront c'est celui de
notre journaliste
c'est la première fois que vous voyez un
iphone oui combien vous fabriquez
d'iphone par jour beaucoup je sais pas
2000 2500 des milliers de téléphones
assemblée 24h sur 24 entre autres par
nos trois adolescents
un peu plus tard nous essaierons de
savoir combien tu gagnes exactement
léger malaise
aucun des trois ne nous dira combien une
perçoivent à la fin du mois
depuis quelques mois le malaise chez les
salariés de foxconn semble grandissant
surtout depuis la révélation d'une
importante vague de suicides des
ouvriers au sein même de l'usiné
on parle de plus en plus d'une vague de
suicides qui a touché les usines foxconn
au sud de la chine cette année toute
notre famille se met à genoux pour
obtenir la vérité
panique chez foxconn sur ces images les
parents viennent pleurer la mort de leur
enfant sous la pression terry gou le
discret pdg du groupe taiwanais est
obligé de réagir
j'ai quatre cent quarante mille employés
sur ce site je ne peux pas tous les
connaître
quelques jours plus tard pour calmer la
polémique la direction de foxconn invite
plusieurs caméras dans les locaux de
lusine pour une visite très officielle
devant la presse des filets anti suicide
sont même installés dans les étages de
l'entreprise
mais le soir même de cette journée
portes ouvertes un ouvrier de plus
parviendra à se jeter du haut de lusine
l'image d'apple est sérieusement écornée
steve jobs son charismatique patron
réagit maintient malgré tout que cette
usine est un modèle du genre en europe
foxconn c'est vraiment pas le bagne
quand on va sur place bon d'accord c'est
une usine mais quand même ils ont des
restaurants des cinémas et des hôpitaux
et des piscines pour une usine c'est
plutôt chouette
selon un rapport mené par une ong
indépendante qui a interrogé près de
1800 salariés 13 pensant d'entre eux se
seraient déjà évanoui sur leur lieu de
travail
28 % auraient déjà été insultés 16%
aurait été victime de punitions
physiques rencontre aux environs de
lusine avec ce jeune ouvrier de 19 ans
qui tient à garder son anonymat
[Musique]
je travaille 10 heures par jour j'ai un
jour de repos par semaine et quand il y
a beaucoup de travail comme par exemple
à noël il faut travailler tous les jours
quand il y a beaucoup de travail je n'ai
plus aucun jour de repos en moyenne 1
ouvriers de foxconn effectuerez plus de
83 heures supplémentaires par mois soit
plus du double autorisé en chine les
employés ont le choix entre vivre dans
des campus ou louer des chambres foxconn
c'est dans celle là de 9 m² loués à
l'entreprise que ce couple vit tous les
deux travaillent à foxconn depuis un an
leur bébé élevé par sa grand mère est
restée dans leur province d'origine
je pense que personne n'a envie de faire
un travail aussi laborieux non même pour
une courte période on a tous un but
moi aussi j'ai un but mais je ne peux
pas continuer comme ça sinon je vais
mourir
comment vous expliquer tous ces suicides
certains salariés sont plus fragiles
certaines personnes se referme sur
elle-même alors elles ont du mal à
extérioriser leurs sentiments et elles
n'ont plus d'autre choix
elle passe à l'acte c'est dramatique
pour moi ce sont les parents qui sont
responsables tous ces étudiants qui
débarquent ici ils sont trop jeunes
c'est la vérité ils ne sont pas assez
forts
après ce qu'il s'est passé je pense que
les parents auraient dû faire revenir
leurs enfants des enfants utilisés comme
stagiaire pour se fournir en main
d'oeuvre l'industriel aurait passé des
accords avec des écoles dans de
multiples provinces chinoises
des lycéens d'à peine 16 ans serait
ainsi envoyé en masse au labeur une main
d'oeuvre à bas prix comme ici dans cet
autre bâtiment où logent quelques
dizaines de ces jeunes stagiaires
foxconn après 10 heures passées à
l'usiné ou en 17 ans ayant deux saisons
rentre à peine chez eux
la victoire allait bouge toi il est 18
heures et ont terminé leur journée
mais leur troisième co locataire lui
doit prendre son service
seuls livrés à eux mêmes ces enfants
sont venus ici poussés par leurs
professeurs
[Musique]
à l'époque c'est à l'école qu'on nous en
a parlé
notre professeur nous a dit que nous
pouvions partir travailler et que le
salaire serait de 135 euros
pour nous c'était un salaire très élevé
mais une fois arrivé on a été un peu
déçu
[Musique]
venus de leur province rurale
ces jeunes pensaient trouver un niveau
de vie supérieur dans ces grandes villes
aujourd'hui il ose à peine d'écrire à
leurs parents la réalité je ne pense pas
que ma vie soit meilleure que celle de
mes parents
c'est pas évident à dire
[Musique]
franchement je n'ai pas une meilleure
vie que celle de mes parents
sur quels points exactement sur le
salaire sur tous les plans
quel avenir pour ces jeunes ouvriers ce
vent de révolte qui souffle chez les
travailleurs de shenzhen permettra-t-il
de faire progresser la société chinoise
ces dernières années à shenzhen comme
dans d'autres régions le niveau de vie
s'est sensiblement élevé
du coup la plupart des usines commence à
délocaliser leurs activités vers
d'autres provinces du pays encore plus
reculés à la recherche d'une main
d'oeuvre toujours meilleur marché
[Musique]